Hello!
Check!
Check and mate, my young friend.
How about another challenge?
You want to play a round of golf at the club and get some lunch?
Whoever gets to the club last buys lunch.
Stand by to have your wallet emptied by a tractor beam.
Anything is possible but probably not that.
In the middle of the Earth, in the land of the Shire...
...lives a brave little hobbit whom we all admire.
With his long wooden pipe, fuzzy, woolly toes,...
...he lives in a hobbit hole and everybody knows him.
Bilbo.
Bilbo Baggins.
The bravest little hobbit of them all.
Yeah!
Go, Bilbo!
Call Leonard.
Go!
Hey, where are you?
Use your sensors!
No need.
I'm already here.
You're there already?
I feel like I'm stuck in a black hole.
No worries, I can practice my swing if you need to pull over and take a nap.
Smart-ass.
I have been and always shall be your friend.
Really?
I had you!
Nice try.
You missed.
No, no, no, I definitely had you!
Not for a second.
Obviously, you're buying lunch.
Technically, we are not inside yet.
I'll see you inside.
Fascinating.